[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys
weltweiter gibt es wieder ein tolles
weihnachts rezept ich mache heute
toffifee küsse die idee habe ich aus dem
internet und zwar hatte ich nur durch
das problem dass ich einfach zu viel
eiweiß übrig hatte und heute habe ich
das gleiche problem und deswegen gibt es
heute eine ganz tolle eiweiß
resteverwertung
ich habe jetzt hier unten drunter
nämlich einen schönen schoko keks in der
mitte ist ein toffifee und obendrüber
habe ich bc und das ganze nennt sich
auch fehlen küssel und es sieht echt
richtig hübsch aus vor allem wenn man es
mit so einer stern kühle drauf spritzt
und ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal
die zutaten für den müll beträgt und
damit gedanken für den mürbeteig
verwende ich 250 gramm mehl 50 gramm
kakaopulver 100 gramm zucker eine prise
salz 200 gramm kalte butter 1 eigelb und
ein bisschen tonkabohne für den
mürbeteig nehme ich jetzt zuerst die
kalte butter
die habe ich bereits in stückchen
geschnitten die kommt in eine
rührschüssel da kommt der zucker dazu
und das saß jetzt kann ich die drei
zutaten schon mal verbinden
dem ich hier noch das eigelb mit rein
und raus kurz unter
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt noch das mehl mit
reinig gemeinsam mit dem kakaopulver
dann noch ein bisschen tonkabohne
tonkabohne sind ganz ganz tolles gewürz
und das schreibe ich so ein bisschen
nutzen der mürbeteig ist jetzt richtig
schön den muss ich jetzt aber allerdings
noch mal kühl und befürchten weiter
verwenden
deswegen drücke ich ihnen gerne flachen
weil das so schneller abkühlt dagegen ab
und dann kommt da für etwa eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
für die finke verwende ich sechs eiweiß
390 gramm zucker eine prise salz etwas
stärke und 45 ich nehme jetzt zuerst das
eiweiß das kommt hier in der
rührschüssel dann kommt da die prise
salz dazu gibt kurz steif geschlagen
und sobald der schweiz ist vom der
zucker noch langsam dazu und dann kann
die massenfächer fünf minuten
weitergeführt werden
mit den fingerspitzen könnt ihr dann
testen ob der zucker noch da ist doch
was ich schon aufgelöst hat und ich kann
in der zwischenzeit aber schon mal den
teig ausrollen
dafür kenne ich ihn einmal kurz durch
und rollen dann auf einer bemehlten
arbeitsfläche 3 mm dick zu und das geht
am besten mit hilfe von teig hölzern
die können die entweder im baumarkt
kaufen und einfach zu schneiden buchen
hölzer oder ihr könnt es so als tiger
schon bekommen und so kann man den tag
ganz gleichmäßig ausrollen und hat nicht
das problem dass die eine seite dicker
als die andere ist
jetzt nehmt ihr einen ausstecher ich
nehme es ihnen runden und der sollte
einfach etwas größer sein als das trophy
versetzt also habe ich jetzt in einem
ausstecher mit sechs zentimetern
durchmesser
[Musik]
es gebe ich hier noch die stärke dazu
und kann sie vorsichtig unterheben und
auf die mit plätzchen habe ich jetzt
bereits mit ich die tafel viel drauf
gelegt
es kommt dir semester in einen
spritzbeutel
[Musik]
und hier vorne habe ich eine große stern
thüle und werdet damit die masse direkt
aufs tor auf spritzen so dass es
komplett umhüllt ist und dann ist es die
besondere überraschung
[Musik]
letzteren ein bisschen glitzer schnee
drauf so ein bisschen hans glitzereffekt
ich finde das gehört einfach zu
weihnachten dazu und murat darf jetzt
probieren ja wir haben gesucht
ja und zwar wird man sehr sehr berühmter
mann zusätzlich über drei werden und
zwar wir sind gerade dieses haus
gelaufen wenn ein paar sachen geklärt
haben damit hat bei uns den fußboden
gemacht und zwar den sicht wertung
estrichboden oder grappa sachen durch
und schön dass du jetzt habe ich ihn
gerade hier kann schon sagen dass sie
während jetzt tipps gegeben hat für die
pflege und jetzt hat er murata sonntags
beschäftigung kann den boden immer schön
polieren ohnehin wirklich hat er
wirklich gesagt jan morgen kommt jemand
und zeigt mir über den bodensee
und ja es ist da werden natürlich hier
war ganz geplant dass er vor der kamera
steht
wir haben jetzt dürft ihr probieren ja
unter den augen auch die videos übrigen
jetzt da das trägt das ist bislang nicht
so lief wie schnell die kinder auch okay
du kannst jetzt folgt wenn du diabetiker
bist du nicht okay da kann er nicht muss
er noch nicht danke ich ehrlich sein und
er wird nicht weg sein steckt eine
überraschung drin im ort war beim backen
nicht dabei was steckt drin wo ich mir
es ist bald schluss sagen steht den
gästen ein tropfen karamell oder nougat
und es ist ein echt cool weil die füße
gesehen hat recht aufwändig aus und das
sieht dann aus als hätte man lukat
reingeht und karamell und dann noch im
hasenhaus kenntlich gemacht wie dem iran
oder gehabt der code ist hätte ich
vorher frage würde das doppel hier aber
im prinzip muss man echt nur den topf
da reinstecken und dann hat man schon
richtig coolen ein richtig tolles
kleines gepäck kommen wieder
jetzt haben steht da zum problem ok auf
jeden fall ja nächste sich mit den
exporten von mortimer ist dann im sonst
bald ausgemacht
also falls ihr das rezept nach machen
wollt dann schaut auf das blog de vorbei
um euch beiden hat es geschmeckt ja habe
ich noch fotos machen das muss doch
fotos machen danach könnte dann auch
hessen relevant wird nämlich vielleicht
was zur hölle haus mitnehmen
ja ich packe gleich was ein und ihr
könnt sie gerne nachbacken hochladen und
mich dann dabei verlinken wo
übernächsten mal vor weihnachten habe
ich schon wünschen damit also macht's
gut
tschüss kommen hier so gut mitgezogen
[Musik]
ich habe die vision eine
schokoladentorte
zustände wie sie so noch keiner gegessen
hat sally zaubert ein meisterwerk genuss
drei hektar für kalorienbewusste essig
und schokolade habe ich noch nie
verknüpft
schilling 40 stand nur süß das wird eine
richtige geschmacksexplosion
glückshormone garantiert schokolade ohne
reue einfach sally sonntag 16 uhr bei
vox